good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
let's get right to it I'll be meeting my
boyfriend's mother at Christmas and she
only speaks German how do I make this
less awkward well I you should want a
little German I'm sure there's some
German nerdfighters in Commons who can
help you but I can start here's a good
sentence chicks are least I miss a
burrito there's another one ears on East
ein guter kisser can you say anything in
Spanish can I of course may I'm one
better day so you nerd favorite
videogame original Super Mario Kart hey
John how are you today also if you have
any book recommendations
I'm good a little bit annoyed about the
overall quality and political discourse
in the United States but yes I do have
book recommendations I'm just rereading
life on the Mississippi by Mark Twain
which is so good also I just read Toni
Morrison's new novel and I know it's not
her best book or anything but I still
thought it was great give any unpopular
opinions about classic literature I kind
of stand with WH Auden on this one some
books are undeservedly forgotten
none are undeservedly remembered is
there anything you aren't terrified of
that you should be no I don't want to
brag but I sort of specialize in being
terrified do you think everyone should
consider taking a hiatus from social
media like you have I don't know but I
can't say I haven't missed social media
as much as I thought I would it had
become a really unhealthy place for me
in a lot of ways the last like eight
years I've been surrounded by a
community online that is incredibly
generous and kind to me into my work and
criticism is almost always been really
thoughtful and respectful but there's
been this small but persistent amount of
really vicious and hateful stuff
directed at me that I just have found
tremendously hurtful and it hasn't been
good for my mental health and yeah and
while there are definitely things that I
miss about my old internet life I find
it much easier to write and do other
work without all of that stuff floating
around in my head speaking of writing
what's your new book about I can't say
because I don't know which parts of what
I'm writing is going to actually end up
in a book but I did put a clue for you
in this video but you won't be able to
decode the clue until after you read the
story so it's kind of useless I'm sorry
Joe Reed heading Manko yes of course
Michael was a great Swedish crime
novelist who sadly died yesterday I
always admired him not just for his
stories but also because he made a lot
of money and gave almost all of it away
he wants what I still have a photo on my
wall of the greatest idol I will ever
have myself at age 8 because that's when
the forces of the imagination have the
same value as the real world when
they're an instrument of survival when
my mother disappeared and I imagined a
mother that was me at my best
what's your signature dish you know
there's that like small plate that's for
desserts and there's that big plate
that's for dinner and then
there's that medium-sized plate that's
sort of all-purpose I am a huge fan of
this medium plate my signature dish
would you be interested in becoming the
next manager of Liverpool Football Club
oh yeah I already sent them a resume my
qualifications include having taken AFC
Wimbledon from league two to the
Champions League in FIFA 14 and having
an inside track on one of the world's
best youth players Henry Green they're
an animal you'd like to see in the wild
I'm pretty into tuatara lately how
prepared do you feel for your drag race
against Maggie stevedore on Friday well
I actually have a friend who's a
professional racecar driver so I
consulted with her on this topic and she
said John you really you need to be
prepared to lose and so in that sense I
guess that I'm I'm very prepared would
you rather be a sheep or a goat
definitely sheep I've always wanted to
be a sheep because then when people are
like hey where'd you get that sweater I
could be like oh I did it myself
using my own hair what's the most
impressive word you use in casual
conversation I use the word
eschatological a lot because there's no
shorter word that means the exact same
thing and kind of my default emotional
stake is eschatological anxiety what's
your best advice for traveling with
children when possible don't
what's the greenest green you've ever
seen John Green is forests in Brazil
when it was raining and everything was
impossibly green but everything in a
slightly different shade it was really
was like home for greens if you could
travel anywhere you wanted and lived
there for a year where would it be
honestly if I could stay anywhere on
earth for a year right now it would be
this house hey who's your style icon I
think you mean Styles icon if you could
be stuck in the world of any TV show or
movie what would it be
Star Trek The Next Generation please let
that happen please let that happen
please let me open my eyes and be
hanging out with Wesley Crusher three
two one dang it Hank I suspect when it
comes to that last question you and I
are in agreement I will see you on
Friday both at nerdcon and on YouTube